hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep I'm still starstruck
because on this episode we have the Real
Housewives of Atlanta oh gee NeNe Leakes
herself I gonna tell you I don't
remember anything I asked her this whole
episode was so fun and so sweet and
she's so beautiful and she's so lovely
and I am so excited that she even made
time to come on to not too deep so enjoy
this episode of not too deep with miss
NeNe Leakes ever in the mood for a great
tasting beer but not the buzz that comes
with it
enter Brooklyn breweries special effects
a delicious flavorful brand new brew
that happens to be non-alcoholic special
effects is not just for folks who don't
drink alcohol it's for anyone who wants
to do more with their days and nights
head to Brooklyn Brewery comm slash
special effects for more info and to see
where you can pick up a six-pack or two
near you so tell me about grace this is
grace Nene this is not your podcast
people need your actual advice on
managing my social media because I've
been looking first of all thank you for
being here thank you for having me of
course second of all I'm like a giant
Housewives fan obviously um and you're a
like longevity of career is like so
inspiring and very cool to watch thank
you it's a lot it's a lot and as the day
that we're recording this on the 18th
your premiere episode of Real Housewives
finally went up last night yes did you
know that it was gonna be three episodes
into the season I do you did okay so you
get a heads up beforehand yes okay I
need to know one are you exhausted
because the amount of [ __ ] that you do
is exhausting to watch happen you know
what there are days when I'm exhausted
yeah last week I was exhausted yeah
because I did
I did La Bahamas Miami somewhere else I
don't know it's just everywhere in a
whole week but it's me yeah and not only
are you doing the show but you have
12,000 other entrepreneurial endeavors
that you are managing at the same time I
love be the mantra preneur yeah I am a
serial entrepreneur yeah and I always I
was just at the Mexican place talking to
the owner bye-bye so yeah if you're
gonna get a 10% stake for you know
$200,000 even having you know multiple
streams of income yeah that's why I
asked you about how do you do this I
mean did you get it like this it's very
similar even though it's very different
that it's like you make a living being
yourself doing something but then at the
same time like you said you have all
these different pots on the stove
because you never know which one's gonna
boil over which one's never gonna boil
and so there's I think not an obsession
but just like a fulfillment in being
busy in doing things and keeping things
going and you've been doing that I mean
you've been on housewives for 11 years
now eleven seasons eleven seasons and
we're in our 12th and I shot the pilot
so that was 13 G's and how can you talk
me through the beginning of signing up
for the show um okay so I actually was
approached by a girlfriend that I know
us and associates association
you start banging away she said we were
girlfriend you know we just know each
other okay so this girl was an associate
of mine and she said the producers from
the Orange County housewives were going
to be in Atlanta and they're looking for
Orange County housewives not the girl
that is so stupid this is Atlanta why
would they be looking for Orange County
housewife so she was she just had it all
wrong but she was just like no but they
are looking for girls that live behind a
game I said girl that's me you should
refer not baking that she really had a
could make it she's just as like this
regular gorgeous sitting big hat sure
makes you know anything had you seen
Orange County I was a fan okay I really
loved Vicki and all those I had a really
big thing from oh my god he's with
Gretchen they're played slay yeah and he
was with Jojo Jojo oh yeah and so I
interviewing the lady calls me up and I
was just blowing her off because I
didn't think she was real sure finally I
was like yeah yeah yeah
can you come over tomorrow 1:00 so she
comes over and I forget I would say at
home mom for real yes so I was cleaning
my house I'm not a breakfast either so I
got me a bottle of wine and started
drinking it and cleaning my house so by
the time the lady came and I opened it
even get out of my neighborhood she we
want you on the show who are your
friends like Kim Zolciak Sheree
Whitfield Deshawn snow yes I came to
realize so it really is like that that
they asked for your actual friend group
and they kind of vet them and figure out
like what the energies work for the show
they told me that Kim Zolciak was going
to be a no really yeah because they were
looking for our african-american girls
okay and that she was not
african-american and I said well okay
all right
so one day the producers were at a
restaurant and I in I had Kim to come
uh-huh and when they finished looking
and talking to Kim they were like okay
she's gonna be known
white girl with all these black girls
because she came here you know just
doing all kind of stuff yeah they were
like okay we have to use her yeah I mean
it's such a
bonkers journey and to be at the start
of it it feels I mean there's like
legacy there yeah we shot a pilot so it
was me sure a would feel and Kim Zolciak
and and other girls who didn't make it
in the show okay but we shot the pilot
and we waited for a whole year for it to
get picked up Wow you know shooting and
shopping and they get him picked up yeah
and all that and then they came back and
we shot a season 1 but we shot the pilot
was never seen how has I mean because
it's really so nuts to me like agreeing
to put your life out there in a public
way and then you also you know made a
pivot and you went more of the acting
route of traditional acting and then
kind of pivoted and came back and how do
you take like your temperature unlike
deciding to say yes to another season in
the very beginning when we said yes we
didn't really know what we were saying
yes - right okay so there were reality
shows like the real world and the
Osborne's and flavor flavor yeah yeah
you know but that wasn't really what we
were so it wasn't exactly sure what we
were getting into
okay but every year I honestly must say
that I I have some reservations every
season yeah it's a lot it's a very big
show issues for a very long time
yeah what six months shooting period and
that's a very long shoot it's everyday
shooting except for Sunday and Monday
really yeah we do get other days off and
during the week but you just don't know
what those are sweets berries they'll
just let you know if you're on call
basically yeah yeah and so that's it's a
tough schedule we have to travel with
the show and our families are a part of
the show it's a huge footprint yeah so
every year it's sort of like should I or
shouldn't I hey and that's not because I
don't love the show it's because
the energy like just I don't know if I
want to have that sort of energy year in
and year out well you guys started it
before social media was a massive thing
and so now this is such a major part of
your show and such a like ancillary part
of this that it's tough yeah people say
whatever they want to say yeah how do
you I'm not doing well and it's truly
but like as someone's on TV and like
I've lived on the internet for the last
decade doing stuff yeah it's still
really hard to let something like wash
over you when someone cuz you have to
defend yourself you know any times
especially people are only getting like
a slice of the full story
well for me I it just depends on what I
see him and how I'm feeling yeah so if I
see something that I know it's not true
it's just so negative and it just
depends on my mood I might just be like
you know whatever they said yeah but if
I'm not in the right mood I fire back
yeah it actually feels really good that
you were on a flight you're getting on
the flight to come to LA and that you
would let everyone handle everything but
then there was immediately right I know
so many flights in sometimes they like
yeah there's now yeah that first thing
when I got on their team that was
working and I was like honey here we go
did you watch the episode before it
aired yeah you did okay have you watched
the whole season before now this is the
first so you guys watch it in real time
with everyone else I'd like to watch
what everyone that's what we get it on
Thursday okay okay so Thursday before
well it's it's enough to have it to
Sookie
yeah I need a couple days to be like
really realize what happened yeah
knowing that people are going to say
something by Sunday you know you're good
yeah you know you've already seen it
yeah I've even walked in hands of the
Lord did you find your spiritual healer
actually I found her on social media you
did okay
I had been following a couple of
different women out of Atlanta and and I
just been watching her for a while and
we deal with each other a few times and
talked and you know we decided that we
would get together and we did and I'm
kind of happy that I did yeah because
she gave me a lot of great exercises to
do she told me a lot of positive things
I think mostly with a life coach yeah
they just try to get you to make
decisions so pretty much she's just like
Nene this is what you need to do yeah
like you need to put one foot in front
of the other
now I've always been a decision maker I
don't know how I got to this place in my
life why I just got kind of stuck yeah
I don't know what I want to do and when
I don't want to do mm-hmm and it's it's
she was able to help me today sometimes
it's really simple seeming but it's
impossible to see it for yourself yeah
and having someone just kind of on the
outside giving you that very like
repetitive kind of advice breaks down a
lot of walls I think that's a very
relatable thing that people go through
especially when you're just like
constantly creating content constantly
creating businesses constantly like it's
40 people yeah so sometimes you get
tired new I don't know what the funny
I'm doing right now and I don't know
which way to go well okay so ladies of
success tour yeah can we talk about that
what is that for people that don't know
um ladies
success is Beauty Brains and business
suck a similar like a conference or
summit that you'd like to say okay for
entrepreneur women and I created it
because I one of the things where I have
lots of girlfriends that come around me
and I find out after they've been around
me they've gotten everybody's phone
number everybody's number and they were
talking in the beginning I was not cool
with that
saying I was just like you know like
that's so weird to me like every time
you write you get everybody's phone
number like for what you know I mean you
don't know them you could possibly like
everybody that you meet so I decided to
start something where like-minded women
could rub elbows what I learned is that
some of those women who were around me
they had elevated to a new level they
weren't cool entertainment industry they
weren't celebrities but in their own
little way they had elevated you know
they were making more money than a lot
of their friends and they wanted to be
with the like-minded women I mean who
could do some of the things that they
could do they wanted to rub elbows with
you know a different class of woman yeah
and so I decided to create this same for
women entrepreneurs to be able to come
together and form relationships and
become business partners and investors
and friends for life that's very cool
you know what it's by far one of the
best things I've done I loved it is this
the first one that you don't want okay
it turned out so good that's awesome I
just loved it in and we call ourself a
circle okay so I loved using the word
like you want to be a part of a circle
and so women want to be a part of a
certain circle yeah and there's also
people want to be a part of something
yeah so now that the the conference has
ended we're still in contact with each
other like doing a Black Friday shopping
for all the women who can do it there's
like to New York and we'll shop I'm
having a Christmas party I'm inviting
some of the women I really connect it
with there are other women who all met
each other from across the world they're
friends for life now they have
girlfriends and they can call on now
when I go to North Carolina I can call
this girl
Texas I can call back girl and it's
really a cool thing and the plan is to
do more of them as many as I can I want
to do two out of the country okay and I
want to continue to do the one here in
the States
my husband has created a thing for men
as well greg has made something he's
done it's called the minion air so now
because you know what happened when I do
the maze of success yeah most of the
girls men were around but they were in
the hotel hanging out because they flew
with a lot of girls who are successful
they generally you know they may have
one or two girlfriends but their their
their boyfriend or their husbands like
they're their partner dog yeah so
they're with those guys and my husband
was there too
right I try to keep them out of this one
in every bit I was going out so this is
for women Greg thank you but so we
decided to do something for the guy
that's great how do women become a part
of this if they're interested you can go
to our website which is ladies of
success Miami ok calm very cool ok we're
gonna take a quick break when we get
back I have more questions for you then
we have a bunch of Twitter questions for
you because you know you love Twitter
we'll be right because we're not too
deep support for today's show comes from
ShoeDazzle if you want to embellish your
go-to outfits and staple pieces with a
new pair of shoes without breaking the
bank
check out ShoeDazzle every month
ShoeDazzle debuts a new selection of
exclusive and brand name shoes handbags
and more after taking a quick style quiz
you'll get your own custom online
showroom with items based on your own
personal style shop there or browse the
site freely to find the perfect style
for you ShoeDazzle is for every woman
whether your style is classic edgy
feminine or glam check out as a guest or
become a VIP get 30 to 50% off regular
prices plus free shipping on orders over
$39 I love ShoeDazzle you know I'm a
boring person when it comes to clothes
but you know a good accessory spices
things up and gives the illusion that
you got you
stuff together so get your first
ShoeDazzle style for as low as $10 as a
VIP at ShoeDazzle calm slash grace
that's 75% off your first item at
ShoeDazzle dot-com / grace you'll also
get free shipping on orders over $39 and
there's no commitment when you purchase
your first order make sure you enter
your email address when you take the
style quiz to get exclusive discounts
and the inside scoop about new
collections again go to ShoeDazzle comm
slash grace s h o da ZZ le comte grac e
terms and conditions apply we're back
okay Nene who out of the Housewives
franchise were you most starstruck - me
me start the meeting if you could
imagine yourself ever being star okay
who in let's say traditional Hollywood
have you ever been the most impressed to
me or most excited you know it's weird
because I've never really had that
starstruck thing is the person that I
saw that I was really excited about
meeting but they were really not kind so
I'm not even talking about them great
but I will tell you about there is I
have to say and I've met some of
everybody
gaga I was cool that's very cool I have
to say JLo was very cool I thought she
was beautiful fabulous I mean look at
her then you could do about that so but
I'm not you know a very starstruck
person really
when I saw Gaga I think you know I
happen to know her manager at the time
and I was like mm-hmm
let me see and she was very kind yeah
that's great and then Jayla was very
kind yeah I mean they feel like they're
professionals Tootsie
I mean it's why they have so much
success well you know that's our talent
like super Kai what people pull it on
you all day so I was you know I was
really happy that they were high that's
great yeah so you've created a lot of
products from you know being on
television out of all of the other
products that housewives have created
are there any that stand out to you they
like that was a great idea well you
gotta give it up to Bethany I mean that
was a great idea yeah I mean she has
done it you know with everything skinny
this is skinny that she did a great job
yeah I mean I'm still waiting for
Sonja's microwaves
did she ever toaster oven oh my bad egg
on my face I really wanted so I don't
know why did she want to do a toaster
man no one knows why Sonja does anything
that she does but I mean no one really
knows that someone gave her a patent to
do one do you watch like what do you
watch on television I don't really watch
TV
really I used to really be into TV
uh-huh but my schedule is so busy yeah I
get home I'm really like you know what's
your relaxation thing I don't know what
you know I don't maybe reading is
probably better for me and I a lot of
times when I have free time like that
I'm working I am like I get online I
really need to know how to turn my brain
off because I don't do that very well
okay I could still be you know answering
emails just doing all kind of stuff and
never really just yeah settling down
yeah actually taking dare go to the spa
oh no really because they want your
phone I need my
[Laughter]
so you haven't taken a break you haven't
taken any time off oh really
not really but they say right to work
that yeah if you love what you do then
you never work a day in your life yeah
the let's talk about like traditional TV
hmm is that more do you want to get more
into that world of course yeah cuz you
just can play right I've done Broadway a
couple times right and I just did a play
I've done plays after you know I loved
the whole theatre world
uh-huh I would love to go back to
Broadway yeah I love scripted television
so yeah I'd love to be in all those
areas is there an ideal role that you
would want no I feel like I'm open to
anything I bet a lot of people you know
tend to cast me as the funny lady or the
outspoken woman but I'd like to try
something that's a little bit different
than that really yeah I think that'd be
very cool
and you did a comedy tour as well I'm
still doing they're still gonna comment
yes we are back out on the road in
February I think we 2020 you'll be on
the road back on the road again with the
same girls Loni love Sherri Shepherd
Dale you know that seems like it's the
most goes on yeah and you I mean because
you just sort of got into that world a
little while ago how is that bad I love
it yeah
I actually really loved it it to me is
its stage once again right and I love
stage and I feel like it's easy yeah and
on this show I am the host okay so I
come in and out of each comment mm-hmm
so I open the show and they come out and
they performed and I come back and I
bring out the next one so I'm hosting
that's good oh that's the one thing I
want to ask you about yeah Zumanity
Zumanity yeah so I went to Zumanity
with it ex-boyfriend years ago and we
kind of didn't know what we were
watching and the host of the show made
this Midwestern couple next to us very
very uncomfortable to the point that the
guy ended up leaving and then the
girlfriend had to like run after him and
I loved every second that that happened
he was just way too overly sexualized
for this like very conservative
Paul that also it's just like I don't
know I thought we were going to start to
solidity doing all kinds of grinding on
each other had you had any like crazy
experiences during that show I mean it's
a wild show no when they asked me to do
it yeah I flew me in to see the show
okay so when I saw the show I was I was
like something about this I'm like me
and my husband said you are not doing
anything like this you cannot do a show
totally against it and I said hey I'm
doing this show I did it I did a run
okay maybe I don't know six weeks that's
two days you know what was weird is that
I lived in Vegas in the casino oh that
that was weird
that feels like every night coming down
yeah that was cool that is there
something in the entertainment world
that you haven't done yet that you want
to do I probably would like to do more
movies really yeah I don't really do
movies that often okay and so that's
something I'd love to do yeah that seems
like something that you should do yeah
sometimes when you're in Hollywood you
kind of get put in like in a little box
I'm TV so I'm TV right right yeah yeah I
do YouTube stuff and so if I go on
auditions it's always like the girl from
YouTube and so it's very hard to like
prove to people that you're like this
honey
yeah do you still feel like that I can't
like I said I would love to do movies
yeah when I walk in they pretty much are
my your TV Oh interesting yeah that's so
nuts that that still happens to you yeah
okay let's say you had to design a
tattoo for all your fellow housewives to
get what would you have them all get
tattooed Oh what would I have them get
as a tattoo and I don't have one tattoo
so I don't have any so I don't know
tattoo world but I probably get them I
don't know maybe they should I put a
stop sign
[Laughter]
wonderful wonder in your opinion best
and worst hairdo that you've ever had
I've had lots of worse hair dude and
I've had you know good hairdos I mean
you know one of the things about me is
you know whatever it is I rock it yeah
you know sometimes you start out in the
morning thinking your hair gonna be good
and bad but that both I've had both good
and bad hair side yeah I mean also
everything is documented for you of
everything that you've ever
you can literally Google my bad hair day
and all kind of pictures do you follow
any because I know all the time on the
show everyone's like the blogs the blogs
the blogs are their blogs that you guys
like specifically keep up with - keeping
track of things honestly I mean I don't
always shake them yeah as far as social
media follow some bloggers yeah okay I
followed the shade room oh yes yes I
follow the Housewives blog there's lots
of those are there Housewives Atlanta
okay I haven't done a deep dive into
that world okay a few like fashion blogs
gotcha yeah have you guys shot the
reunion for this season no we usually
don't shoot it to like February March oh
okay so they let you guys watch the
whole season basically before the
seasons not over your season is always
April May okay oh wow so you guys do the
reunion before the seasons even
completely oh yeah because they have to
edit it in and all that
right right right and it's a big day
it's a big I know cuz we do it about six
weeks before it actually shown okay got
you gotcha who is the funniest person
that you know the funniest person that I
know I know how it's funny people I mean
I'm on the comics okay so I know a lot
of you know I mean funny is I know
that's I don't know but I know a lot of
funny people how did you okay then how
did you develop the the lineup for the
Comedy Tour I
actually didn't develop it myself I work
with my agency at ICM uh-huh and they
with me you know chose girls they
thought that would be well on the toy
that's great
and it's gone so well that it's
happening yeah you know we've been doing
it oh no maybe you want our third year
third year yeah we started out second
definitely two years already there's
probably two and a half years we've done
it and then we take a break because you
know like a lot of the girls work on
television like I has a talk show Cherie
works on a scripted show right now and
so everybody has work schedule what's
the different energy and hanging out
with housewives first hanging out with
comics for the comics most of us are
serious people we are like more serious
kind of like sure serious as in we can
go out and be funny and do all that but
then really when we're back professional
yeah everybody's pretty serious like
it's it's you haven't know how a lot of
comics operate yeah I'm really different
people mm-hmm yeah well it's also like
they're total pros even though you can
go onstage and make a fool of yourself
behind the scenes you're actually often
totally are like you know what I'm about
to go sit in this corner and be quiet
like yeah housewives are doing the most
[Laughter]
okay take one last break when we get
back we have a bunch of Twitter
questions for you so I'll be right back
but not UD a better way to get birth
control is finally here with simple
health simple health is all about care
that fits your life
they make birth control simple
convenient and affordable with online
prescriptions and free home delivery
whether you're brand new to birth
control are just tired of dealing with
renewals and pharmacies simple Health
will take care of you you just fill out
an online health profile then a doctor
reviews it and writes a prescription you
can pick the birth control you want or
have a doctor recommend the best one for
you including the patch or the ring your
birth control then ships to your door
monthly no more waiting room
no more pharmacy lines and no
interruptions simple health isn't a
replacement for routine checkups with
your doctor but they make birth control
accessible for all women it's free with
most insurance plans and starts at $15
per month without insurance don't miss
your chance to try simple health for
free just go to simple health.com slash
n TD or enter code n TD at checkout
again that simple health.com slash n TD
or n TD at checkout all right we're back
with Nene and I'm gonna ask you before
we get into these Twitter questions the
two questions asked every single guest
that's on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at it can be a
celebratory attack like you but listen
at the end of the day I'm just like girl
I just okay I get over you are on a
spiritual journey I guess you can I just
can't give that energy up yeah no that's
very fair save the spaghetti the other
question that I ask every single guest
is to tell us your worst pants [ __ ]
story or close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases so
mine is college jogging front lawn now
what's the question me so tell us your
worst and pants [ __ ] story or a
close call but you can only use three
words okay so this is so personal
I have irritable bowel syndrome okay so
it's not like I'm having too many close
call I'm trying to have a call can I go
to the bathroom
my girl and used the bathroom this week
so I don't think I've had close calls
like that I need to just have a bathroom
moment okay well here we are all hoping
and wishing for 2020 to be a much more
[Laughter]
okay let's get into these Twitter
questions asked Tara says
Nene you were [ __ ] hot what are your
thoughts on Kenya Moore being back just
to be honest with you and I've said this
many times before
I think he is great for the show yeah
she's not the show but she is great for
the show yeah yeah yeah and so my
feelings about her returning me is
anybody can return anybody can come on
the show that's gonna keep this show
around for the next 10 20 15 years as
follow me mm-hmm that's a very I means I
need my check to see Clara wants to know
ask her how does one stop being a clown
stop being a clown who does that mean
like silly funny
I think stop being like jerk yeah
how do they stop me a jerk yeah no ask a
question I'll be some inner
soul-searching ain't it very fair
Caroline wants to know your favorite
Housewives franchise moment was a
prosthetic leg throat table toss white
house crashing scooter ah well you know
scooters an easel yeah of me I love when
Theresa tossed the table at the table it
was iconic moment really was also her
arms look so ripped in them they test
them to know if you were to switch
housewife cities which city would you
choose I would come here to Beverly
Hills you would yeah really why is that
because they need me to get them
together
yeah you know they meet it feels like
Vanderpump's on her way out anyway so
they make me she's not a face she's here
I feel like she's on her way out of
Beverly Hills like she's slowly kind of
like movie she's not on the show that
I'm damaged she was on the show this
past season but she's out okay well then
there you go now there's a seat open for
you Scott wants no favorite alcoholic
beverage vodka perfect that's why they
same
yeah very same Rachel wants to know do
you use your own gifts to respond to
people's texts or gifts actually I don't
so many people send them to me oh really
social medium I'm rolling up and down
the screen I mean you have an amazing
collection I have a really big
collection it's funny huh yeah I opened
up I don't need to check from that I
know how do you really feel some kinda
way yeah I opened up the Bravo con blog
just to catch up from the weekend cuz I
have a paid attention and it's like day
three comes to a close it's just a Jif
view and I'm like you weren't even there
I was even there no I didn't even go
someone to know how have you found out
where Kim scooter is if you could draft
a fantasy housewives team who would you
take from each city so let's say we put
six housewives into like a mega
housewives mmm new franchise who would
you choose from here I would probably
take Kyle Richards because I like her
yeah a friend of mine I'm and then I
would move on over to New Jersey take
Teresa cuz she's a friend of mine
yeah New York and I would take dang well
Bethenny is not there I would take Jill
Zarin she's back and Ramona oh yeah okay
so that's four and then where we at so I
need two more including you anywhere any
of the franchisors mrs. Orange County I
like I like Vicki okay there's also
Dallas I'm always down with the OGS no
so just take note yeah
I was down with LG's and then Dallas I
don't even know who's on that show never
ever seen that cut-ups atomic Potomac I
would grab gizelle okay I mean that
would be a really great franchise I
would watch that Oh some pretty big
fights on there I mean it but also I
think there'd be a lot of respect for
each other it's like Oh genus need to be
Jo doesn't have a question he just wants
you to know that he misses full frontal
fashion okay
full frontal fashion was that I'm asking
you that question is that on your
YouTube channel
Oh fashion police I guess also you have
your YouTube channel yes
how do you how are you managing that
well I haven't been very lately okay um
I had a girl that was doing it she moved
out of the state and stuff like that so
I really did take the time to find
someone else yeah
also I don't know how you don't have a
your own podcast I've been offered it
feels like a very natural thing that
wouldn't take up a ton of your own time
it just feels like a few times well I
have fingers crossed that it happens
hopefully favorite reality show besides
Real Housewives mmm honestly I love I
like loving hip-hop yeah it's a no you
know much I watch it okay what did you
think of peppermint snatch game
performance of you I didn't see that on
RuPaul's Drag Race oh I didn't see I
hope it was good it was very great I
think you would be very very lovely
someone wants to know how is Real
Housewives changed your relationship
with your children
oh my relationship my shoes I don't know
my children would like for me to not be
so public about everything really pretty
private yeah they don't want me to be
like I talk about everything but you've
done a great job of making them like
allowing them to have a private life on
Viceroy's yeah I will have to say the
boys operate a little bit different I
think it sure a lot of people are asking
me how's everything going with you and
Greg everything is more I'm really good
with Greg eMac okay
actually just FaceTime I think he likes
me
you might have a crush on you I don't
know I have a small crush on me here
Nicole wants to know how do you stay
looking so good like for real well for
real I do watch what I eat from time to
time you know hacking I kind of like
this I can get to a certain place I can
feel my clothes not working right mm-hmm
and then I know to push away from a
table
I don't wear makeup when I'm not working
oh that's good because I I love good
healthy skin ya know and pray just pray
for no wrinkle you can't go see the
doctor with a meet oh honey I like tea
serious okay last couple of questions
what you have you've seen someone that's
done your favorite impression of you oh
I've seen about it you know guys do me
oh that's so good but yeah I have yeah
okay here's the last question it's
actually a really thoughtful question
after a lifetime has passed this is AJ
wants to know well into the future
you've had such a huge career what do
you hope your legacy will be for your
viewers fans and family what do you want
people to remember or learn from you
well you know I would want people to
just remember or learn the bet I I want
to empower you know in my own little way
you know and also you know be on a
reality show like this in front of
cameras people never watch me I mean
since I was in my 30 right you know
they've watched me you know marry
divorce become a grandmother I mean just
a number of things so not for nothing I
would love for them to walk away with
the fact that I have a heart and I want
to empower other women oh that's
beautiful
I also think there's a big message of
like resilience there - yeah Nene thank
you so much for being here before you
leave completely every guest on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie from us - you guys you don't have
to eat it in fact
not eating it because you have bags of
tacos waiting for me but you're welcome
to open it and read the fortune that's
inside oh you do guys here they roll
this huge budgets Nene your [ __ ] it
would be a success as long as it's a
really really really good idea and does
really really really really well being
yes it will be a success a success
guaranteed there you go thank you the
cookie has spoken cookie or smokin Thank
You Nene where can people find
everything that you're up to
like tour info you online if they don't
know our you can find me on social media
at nene leakes on all platforms okay um
let me see I got all kind of websites
oh geez me face so ladies our success
ladies of success miami.com
great you gotta help me Oh ladies night
out tour oh you know we don't have a
website for that okay what we do is you
search I mean check our social media
platforms it will tell you each city
where to purchase tickets generally is
that ticketmasters I feel like if people
just follow you on Instagram and Twitter
they'll find all of the everything that
you're looking for a really nice week
you can go to color see yellow our main
ma e wigs wogs calm we have a black girl
white girls out hence the girls amazing
I mean yeah I hope at some point in 2020
you get to sleep because you are just
constantly busy and your concept
today's arrests here and there but I you
hustle I like what I do well thank you
so much for being here this has been so
fun thank you for having me thanks for
listening watching guys we'll see you
next time on not too deep goodbye
goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep
not too deep is a production of grace
Helbig incorporated producer Melissa Dee
months camera operator Katrina Henning
edited by Shireen Lana unis
post-production sound by Chris Henry
and an extra special thanks to Flula for
the theme music
[Music]